[Music]
alright Contras so nice to meet you
great meeting you thank you for coming
over here I've been looking forward to
meeting you for a very long time
consider myself a big fan and a loyal
longtime follower you're amazing and
your story is is just insane things that
you've been able to do and what you've
had to overcome to be this incredible
person that you are so I'm excited to
explore it with you thank you so the
latest thing you just did was you
conquered these three to hundreds right
in a row three to hundreds within ten
weeks within 10 weeks 650 plus miles of
racing
so three they're not loops short loop
courses these are mountainous courses so
the first one was Big Foot 200 in
Washington which was very very technical
around Mount st. Helens a huge loop
crazy condition very very rugged like
you were out there and so you had to
make sure that you carried enough gear
for 20 miles in between up to ten hours
by yourself and then the second one was
Tahoe 200 which I had done before and
that one in dusty dirty Rubicon Trail
lots of climbing hot you know conditions
and this last one was in Moab and it was
240 miles and it actually got extended
because there was so much snow up in the
higher elevations where's Posca at 10-5
that she couldn't send us up there it
would been up to our crotches and so
9,000 but we still had like a good 7 to
10 miles of snow to deal with
Wow so reason cold tail so yeah it ended
up being like 3 or 4 miles longer or
something yeah and W 243 miles right so
it was actually 5 because it was 238 how
much how much time in between these two
hundreds they were like less than a
month right so you're constantly like
when you finish you're recovering and
then you're tapering yes and there's no
right if there's no in-between like
really long running I think I did once
or twice a couple of 20 mile long runs
but there was no reason to it was like
10 miles at tops when I'm going on right
mountains that I mean that's kite for
people that are racing ultras all the
time the races are the training right
in between your maintaining or your
tapering or you're just trying to absorb
the fitness that you garnered as a
result of the race yep
I mean it's just amazing and are you the
first woman to do what's it called the
Triple Crown no but I think it's the
oldest woman oldest female 53 yeah so
there was yeah there there was no other
women in their fifties doing the triple
I don't they started doing it but not
everybody finished so last year two
women finished and I believe this year
seven of us seven females finished
finished all three all three of them
mm-hmm
so it only started last year uh-huh well
the Moab 240 has gotten a lot of press
in the last year or so because of
Courtney - Walter like just crushing
everybody I don't know what you saw if
she I haven't been following it that
closely so this year she was in the lead
pretty much the whole time at Tahoe and
then she started having stomach problems
and only lost the lead within the last
ten miles so she was racing another guy
the whole entire time so did she end up
second then yep and she got the blue the
woman's course record out of the water
so she was faster than the year before
they both broke the course record so so
it didn't he was right you know he broke
the overall course record and her time
was still an overall course record what
is it what's going on with her she's
amazing she is she's so sweet to it I
know you've heard interviews with her
and she's like oh I don't know I just go
and I run she doesn't wear a watch she
doesn't have a coat she doesn't you know
she's just one of those amazing talented
gifted athletes and she won in western
states this year to write as well so and
she's at this big yard big yard I forget
the name of the race this weekend and
she's gonna try to like do 300 miles
there so it's a four mile four and a
half mile loop every hour on the hour
you start the loop and you go as far as
you can so Cincinnati and wait an hour
and then you start wait to the top of
the hour right so every hour you run for
to ever get time what's up so it's the
aggregate time that's interesting so
that involves speed in a way that most
ultras and how are you gonna sleep right
and how are you gonna like eat you have
to like reap weight in between and so
it'll be interesting to see how well she
does but she's
I heard she was going for like 300 miles
uh-huh so because a friend of mine
Maggie's doing it and she's going for
240 no but it'll yeah weevil well yeah
with the explosion of the sport you're
seeing you know the higher caliber
athletes getting into it and she's she's
dominating like nobody's business right
now exactly cool to see and I think
she's she's a still a schoolteacher yep
like it's like she should be like
somebody should just pay her you know a
lot of money I know I don't make it's
like not very many people make money I
mean you make money promoting product
and that's what I'm doing a lot of now
since I've been around for so long we're
gonna have my book out so you know
people pay you to use their products and
to promote it if you like it uh-huh
well your resume is insane like I can't
even say any races it's impossible to
it's not like we can go race by race
through this like I mean alright let's
see over a hundred hundred miles yep
the first u.s. woman to do that only
four people have run over there is okay
so that's 12 now yeah there's at least
four women now 250 plus ultras is that
correct
what else
260 marathons 137 100-mile ours numerous
records the big thing that you did was
was recorded you recorded the fastest
known time for the the Muir ramble right
310 miles in seven days and it was
actually 324 months right I mean went
longer did you get lost or what happened
it's just a real out of route finding
the people that wrote the guidebook they
haven't been out on that course and ages
they did it in 2006 uh-huh so after we
finished it I told them because nobody
had run it and they were like oh you
know there have been fires in the area
and so a lot of the marked yeah so were
you gave her like the beta like I'm like
you need to change it on your website or
you know so if anybody else goes out
there and actually met another woman
doing it when I was out there she saw
her vehicle that said me ramble root
diva Katra and so her and her partner
were driving by so we're gonna go camp
that night because she I was doing some
miles a day and they pull up and they
said who's doing him you're around the
fruit and then I was like oh I am and
she was like really she goes I am too
and I said yeah I'm running and I'm
going for fastest time did you run
together
no she wasn't running it she was blonde
she was from San Francisco and she
started where'd she live cuz it starts
in San Francisco and you take the ferry
to Oakland and that's when you start
your journey by the way he went and she
was just doing like 15 miles a day
uh-huh so and she was a schoolteacher
and just something to do and to talk
about in school and she went back so
right so yeah so I met her and there's
been people that have biked it and a
couple there was only about three people
that have hiked it so I was like because
like I'd never heard of the ramble like
so what is it why is it so obscure so
it's the route is actually the route
that John Muir when he arrived in the
United States in California he decided I
wanted to go to Yosemite and the way
that everybody was going they were going
through like Merced or Sacramento and
taking wagons and it's not the other but
he goes I want to go to the wild way the
way that people aren't going to see all
things wild so he asked somebody which
direction is the wild way and they said
what way I don't want to go where the
people are so he started walking when he
arrived in Oakland and started kind of
along the bay kind of where I live in I
actually used my house as like one night
sleep station and so yeah he just went
along this route and came in Yosemite
through like the back way not on the
traditional way and so there's a lot of
old roads that I was on that are you
still see pieces of pavement coming
through but now they're like totally
abandoned nobody uses these and I was
like really cool being on there because
you know he was on these roads too right
so they made the course as close as
possible to the original way he walked
of course you can't go in the freeway
and there was a couple places where you
were going out fire roads with which
were gnarly like straight up and
straight down straight up and straight
down but they didn't want to put you on
the freeway course and this is different
from the John Muir the big thing yo-yo
record that blows people's minds 400
break after all
yeah don't know why so he's basically
did the whole John Muir Trail turnaround
on top of turn around and went back
mm-hmm and you go from you went I know
you end up at the do you end up it like
the base camp at Mount Whitney or you go
all the way and that's where it starts
even if you start from the Whitney side
if you're starting your John Muir Trail
even though you go up 11 miles then you
don't count that your start is up the
hut right so once you're 11 miles at the
highest point is where you start but I
started from Yosemite went to the top
and then turn around I went back did you
plan on doing the double the yo-yo or
was it just you got there and you're
like I feel good I'm gonna keep going
I know born and born to Bryan they he
acts like I did you I've made up I was
gonna turn around and like who does that
cuz that's I mean that's how I first
became familiar with you like through
through born over which I read before I
got into all this whole world that kind
of put you on the map yeah and there's
before all of our social media too like
nobody you know you didn't have all the
Facebook and anything like that so you
knew who these people were and then when
that when the book came out and then
there was Facebook later on people were
able to Google like who these pictures
were in this yeah so yeah and I
definitely want to do a triple I know my
double is gonna be broken and so now I
live in Bishop and it's close enough to
where I could do it and I've tried to do
it a few years back and my uncle had
passed away so I had to bail him out at
one so I'm gonna definitely do a triple
so bishops like in the middle of nowhere
it's no it's like right next to Mammoth
it's opposed yes 395 thousands of people
drive through it their day they get like
a thousand truckers driving through it
right so it's very popular trails
everywhere though everywhere it's like
climbers are there in the winter because
of all the bouldering buttermilk
boulders and all of this and I have
trawl heads like 19 minute drive from my
house I'm about 9,000 feet from there I
can go right out on the John Muir Trail
I can go ten miles up ten miles down and
I'm on the John Muir Trail it's pretty
cool but you just recently moved there
right where we were so the Bay Area
Fremont near San Jose
I was born and raised there and lived
there pretty much all my life I was
working at twelve Whole Foods for 19
years and I'm still seasonal with them
but my boyfriend has been working for
almost a year now is to see our life
light and so he's a pilot not a
helicopter but airplane and so right
when you leave on live on the east side
as soon as ambulances can't get you to a
hospital fast enough so that's why we
have air ambulance I say that's
interesting to pilot yeah so yeah cuz
we're four hours three to four three and
a half to four hours from Reno and then
four hours from LA so they're your
closest major hospitals I mean we have a
hospital in Mammoth and we have a
hospital and Bishop it if you need any
significant anything yes the dude he's
the dude yeah that's you yep and are you
able to like make all this work on on
sponsor relations like do you can you
make a living doing this how does that
work well you know with my book I'm
hoping to make some money on that and
speaking and stuff like that will
definitely help and I am I mean I with a
lot of my sponsors you know it's like
they give you discount codes and the
more you sell the you know if people are
going through your avenues and buying
stuff you get money so I'm actually
making money yeah yeah yeah I got it I
guess I could live on it I mean my boys
know well I want to drill into the
details of the racing and the training
and how you live your life and all of
that but but I want to go back to the
beginning because the what got you here
is so bananas so so you you were born
and raised in Fremont yes and walk me
through give me a little taste of your
childhood so I was such a girly girl
didn't even like getting dirt on me
always in dresses in patna there were
little shiny shoes and so my parent I
loved dance that was my thing when I was
growing up I loved taking dance lessons
tap dance things like that and my
parents always thought I was very quiet
and I was always like with a book and
kind of hiding and to myself and they're
like well we need to put her in sports
because she's like in team sports so
she's more interactive with other kids
which I had no desire to do and I hated
sports altogether but my father was a
soccer coach and my brother played
soccer who was younger so I was forced
into playing
Walker and softball and I absolutely
hated it I hated running I didn't want
to run I didn't want to sweat I didn't
want to get dirty I hate it at all I
just wanted to take dance lessons but my
parents felt this need to put me in
their sports were you were you always
like an extrovert like were you what we
in high school like we're like rocking
the crazy looks from the get-go no no I
was a little kid but no once I hit
junior high school that's when I started
changing so wasn't using drugs and
drinking and things like that I had two
older sisters so I always was kind of
with the older crowd hanging out with
their friends but yeah we moved when I
was going into junior high school so I
just kind of got into it with the wrong
crowd like right off the bat the kids
that I met and so started smoking what
was going on at home that you think led
you to that nothing that my parents were
great yeah there was nothing going on
there my father was the president
Fremont City soccer I mean my brother
played sports and I just was being doing
my own thing right yeah wild streak that
you had Explorer was coming out I was
coming into my own instead of my two
older sisters were gone now so I'm like
my own person so so junior high that
start happening yes just goes dance
clubs that whole thing doesn't was it
just booze at that time pretty much so
you smoking cigarettes and smoking pot
once in a while and mostly drinking and
just going like I said to discos back
that yeah soccer dad soccer dad probably
wasn't too happy about that
well you know he was in his own thing
with my brother and rewards you know and
I was playing soccer at the time too
right so it wasn't until I got into
junior high school that I was just like
this is what I want to do and my father
passed away at seven when I was 17 and
so that just put me like doing getting
crazier right you know because my mom
now I had to deal with me and my brother
my sisters were already older and they
were married and had their own families
and so my brother that my brother was
with my father when my father died so
then my brother it it didn't he didn't
it didn't he didn't take it very well
and it took he ended up going into
recovery when he was like 15 because he
watched my father died tried to save my
father from having a massive heart
attack now
49 years old yeah and it was that he was
healthy he ran but he smoked you know
and he had quit smoking but he ain't me
and stuff like that but it's not genetic
his his parents live til their 90's mhm
so but yeah that's it your your brother
often that's my brother my mom was
trying to focus on my brother and I was
just going off on my own and then
decided not to go to school and my mom's
like you need to do something because
you can't just not do you know go to
school you need to pick something you
want to do so I went to cosmetology
school uh-huh and so I was doing that
and still like partying going to clubs
and living at home still that yep I'm
still and then I moved out after I
graduated from cosmetology school and
got a job and started I was living with
a boy friend of mine and his family and
we were in and out of you know it was a
horrible relationship back and forth
breaking up you know just he was in a
band and I decided I worse exactly was
he a drummer no he was a lead singer
yeah so then we kind of you know he was
cheating on me and then I met somebody
else and I started cheating on him and
so it was just easy enough to leave that
relationship and so we had this huge
blowout and I ended up with this other
guy and this is not when I was on drugs
I was still I was just drinking a lot
and you know drinking a lot getting
drunk you know when I go out and so this
other guy was a speed dealer and at the
time I didn't know that cuz all my
friends were like don't tell her that
you do that I would notice people coming
in and out of the house and leaving and
you know and then finally one night we
were going to LA to go to a goth club
because I was really big in the goth
scene at this point and he you know they
were all doing speed and I was like I'll
do some you know and so started from
there and it was just like on the
weekends I would do it and then at one
point I was I went to a Lollapalooza
with a friend and she I felt like [ __ ]
them and she's like just do some more
and I'm like no no no I only like to do
it on the weekends and she goes you'll
feel better and I was like ok so I'll do
it so that moment it was the turning
point for me to be like a major addict
with it so when you say speed are you
talking about math math I'm smoking math
yeah and my boyfriend at the time was
shooting it up but I don't even I
pretended like
yeah you knew that one my dramas doing
trying to pretend like yeah in fact I
was so into the drugs that I would
pretend that I was buying it for
somebody else and use my own money to
buy more from him and he gave me so much
a day but then I was doing my amount
that he was giving me and buying more
from him and and at the time were you
partying in Fremont are you going
Francisco and clubs all the golf clubs
that are drug six I mean I just said all
these so what what was it about the goth
scene I just loved it connected to it
yeah I just loved that world like I
don't know anything about that it's very
you know dark negative yeah very
depressing
I just couldn't drive to LA a lot
because a lot of the Cure yeah but those
guys never even did drugs so it's like
look at these bands my boyfriend was in
a band at the time so he was the lead
singer for a band and what was it called
his band was called fleshy gogo and they
were opening for Khan I'm trying to
remember they opened for my life with
the thrill kill Kult a few times and so
you know it was that all that industrial
kind of goth music so and and and what
was the experience like of doing math
for the first time coffee like just you
know and it was like I felt like a
conquer the world like you when you do
it you're like oh you know just chatty
like how I am well confident yes good
energy yeah and you just want to keep
doing it right like you stay up for like
I'm gonna make stuff and get crafty and
make me clean your house and things like
I was making outfits like killer alphas
people release like and so impressed
with like what I was whipping up you
know and I didn't know anything about
anything and just started selling and
making really cool outfits I always
wanted to have the coolest outfit on in
the club so that was my thing and what
what what's the coming down part I feel
like like you just get depressed and if
you already suffering from mental
illness you know which I didn't really
know at the time but I had a lot of that
going on
it gets you know you just got to keep
doing it I stayed above that you know so
you don't have that come down so I
remember at one point my boyfriend
wanted to quit and I was like
[ __ ] no can't quit that means I would
have to quit and I'm not quitting not
quitting yeah and you even came to a
realization one day just like looking at
myself this is my life this is have to
this is how it has to be uh-huh and I
delude yourself again it's sustainable
when it's not yeah when it's not now in
the beginning it's fun but once you
really truly become an addict then
there's no fun anymore you're just
chasing your job you're just chasing it
yeah and when I watch shows about people
like that I just think god I was right
there I understand that and it's sick
it's a sick world did you get to that
place where you're stealing it and lying
to people and all that I had job worked
in hair salons right you're always able
to buy it just on the up but we were
selling it yeah so we were small dealers
getting it and selling it to our friends
and then obviously if somebody told on
us and they didn't want to turn on their
their dealer because that was the big
guy so they said that he had got it from
us so that the cops in him made the
phone call and I answered the phone
and did the sell over the phone so two
days later knock-knock-knock
busting in the door cousin for me and
that becomes like your moment of
reckoning like here your bottom with gel
don't worry I want to work my way up to
that but I'd still I want to know more
about this phase of your life like when
when you kind of when I was doing a
little bit of research and due diligence
on you I mean there's a lot of you know
it paints this picture of a tremendous
amount of chaos there's like there's
incidents of sexual abuse emotional
abuse a string of like very unhealthy
abusive relationships there's there's
eating disorders thrown into there
there's OCD there's it's like it's a
perfect mixture of like of like all
kinds of childhood and psychological
trauma that contributes you know that's
all driving you towards this moment
where you end up in this jail cell yeah
and so I was sexually abused as a child
by a family friend and I kept that
inside all my life my parents even asked
did he touch you in such a way and when
you're a little kid and somebody tells
you and you're you know you're you
respect them and look up to them like
you better not say anything some
it's gonna happen to you so then you're
stuck you lie to your parents and then
you have nowhere to go you know and that
kind of I think set everything how old
were you I was nine so yeah and a family
friend or a family friends a relative
but he was always around our house was
my oldest sister's he was like in her
wedding and like close friend just like
he was always at our house it only
happened the one time but that was
that's enough to change your life and
what's it like carrying that secret
around for so long you know shame you're
scared just and as you get older it's
just like oh now you know it's comes up
you think about it you you know trauma
comes up in life and I I just remember
when I got clean uh sober and when I
finally was able to tell my mom was the
first time in my life I would felt so at
ease like knowing that I was able to
tell her finally after she had asked me
when I was younger and I lied line she's
like why didn't you you know and it oh
yeah she just didn't understand and I
said you don't understand you know and
when I told her when I was like 27 or
whatever you've been like sober for like
well like 25 to 24 years gonna be 25
years and Jan or June 24 so I have to do
something really good so 96 94 94-94 Wow
yeah a long time but what is that like
when you now with perspective and that
much time clean and sober when you look
back on on that incident of sexual abuse
like how do you think about how that
fuel like you're using like what is the
relationship between hiding drug use and
and also like seeking out you know like
this sort of expression of of like
unhealthy you know behaviors as a result
of like harboring that shame and feeling
like you can't tell anyone about it so
yeah I mean it was a constant like
hiding it so if I drank and I was gonna
be with somebody and had a boyfriend and
had to have sex it's like if you're
drunk or you're not aware of what's
going on and somehow it feels better
like you're not you know thinking about
what happened to you cuz you I mean you
must have had intimacy issues like not
trusting people all the time now
now my boyfriend stole awesome huh no as
an adult I'm like you know if people if
people I was married she did not me so
I'm like if people are gonna cheat
they're gonna cheat they got a issue
with himself
you know they if they can't just say hey
I don't wanna be with you anymore that's
perfectly fine I'm a big girl I can
accept it but but because of his alcohol
and drug abuse and whatever that's well
it's weird how childhood trauma
manifests itself later in life through
the repetition of the pattern like you
suffer this trauma and you would think
psychologically you would do everything
in your power to move away from that
type of social dynamic but you seek it
out because for whatever bizarre reason
there's a strange comfort in that or
familiarity I think so too just like I
said when I was marrying my ex-husband
he's nice I mean I don't know what I
want to say anything bad about him but
he wasn't for me but he smoked pot and
he drank a lot it's like why would I get
why would I go with somebody like that
why would I marry somebody like that
people were in shock I mean I met him in
Yosemite was a climber and he just had
this personality like charming fun and
it was right after my mom had passed
away and it just like I connected with
him I just thought he was like so fun
and this that and the other and 24 days
later I married him so in I was clean
and sober there was nothing wrong with
me uh-huh and and then how long have you
been sober at that point well that was
in 2002 so we got sober in 1984 yeah I
just wanted to save in my gasps I don't
know yeah it's something you unconscious
mind that attracts you to that person
and and often those those negative
behavior patterns aren't necessarily
manifest originally like you're just
like oh they're awesome like they're
nothing like that other person that I'm
trying to get away with and then here
six months in and you're like oh they're
exactly like that person yeah he was
definitely a different person and he
progressively I mean if he was not
living in new salmony and climbing that
was he was like just drinking him
getting drunk and just could he couldn't
stand being like controlled in a
controlled environment he need to be
climbing he was a dirtbag
you need to be in the dirt right and if
you have an eating disorder
meth is awesome oh yeah right and I but
my eating disorder really came up
big-time
after I got clean and sober could just
trying to find some control and
something in it like I became vegan and
it was just like that was a good excuse
to why I was getting really thin and so
that went on for a few more years I mean
all my life pretty much you know it's
like the the pictures in the magazines
is all of us women know that growing up
it's like you have this image of
somebody which is not true because I
have friends that are models and they
don't look like those pictures except
for when there's a picture of them you
know it's like there's so much
airbrushing and things going on and and
I'd like that nowadays are using more
normal people average people you know so
we don't have to show our young girls
like this is how you should look when
it's fake you know it's changing but but
there's you know a lot of it is the same
exactly you know and I think that that
speaks to something that is that is that
that I see a lot of which is if you're
an addict an alcoholic or you have some
kind of unhealthy predisposition you can
latch on to a seemingly healthy thing
like I'm gonna be a raw vegan or I'm
gonna be an ultra runner or pick you
know behavior X and you can shade your
unhealthy behavior under the umbrella of
something that people will socially
approve of when you're really yeah right
so you can there's tons of people in
recovery and ultrarunning
there's a reason for that exactly I mean
like you can be very addictive in your
training and that's been something that
I've had you know evolved into like am I
is what is my relationship with this am
i hiding is this making me a better
person or am I just using this as an
outlet because I can't use drugs and
alcohol anymore well we kind of need
something to take we do and you can be a
raw vegan when when it's really not
about that it's because you have an
eating disorder and this is a good way
to like tell everybody that you're doing
something good for yourself when you're
actually not yeah and so how do you like
like what is your
sort of history with all about them so
you know I the eating disorder was early
on when my when I was running so it just
made sense like oh she's getting
skinnier because I was already thin and
then you mom stop doing drugs and you
start gaining I was normal weight it was
something like goes yeah overweight and
then I started running and I became
vegan at the same time so then I
realized I can control this I was eating
like two apples a day it was like
ridiculous that's how controlling I was
with what I was eating and it would
didn't eat in front of people and my mom
shoe apples a day and how much are you
running at that time I was early on but
I'm still running like 80 miles a week
yeah that's the Christian Bale diet from
that movie The Machinist where he got
down to like a hundred pounds yeah well
you want to get really thin and then I
got to a point where I was exercising so
much I was rollerblading to the gym one
day and rollerblading back and it was
like a hundred degrees out and and I
like passed out when I got home and my
mom's like what the hell is wrong right
and I was like rollerblading working out
in the gym and I was like I don't know
and she's like yeah that's not good so I
went to the doctors and she was like do
you have an eating disorder and I'm like
no I'm vegan yeah that's exactly what
I'm talking about
and it wasn't until I started training
for ultras that I actually met a guy on
the trail and he's like you you know I
was saying how it's gonna do 100 miler
and he goes you can do a hundred mile or
he goes you're too thin and I was like
what and it and it's dawned on me at
that point that like maybe there is
something going on and I had went to the
doctors and they saw like I had a heart
murmur and I felt like I was gonna have
a heart attack at some point and I'm
like thinking about my dad am i [ __ ] I
might die you know and so it kind of I
kind of changed it and started reading
more nutritional stuff like about
nutrition and supplements and you know
having a different relationship with
food like eating and taking supplements
that were gonna nourish my body without
eating the junk but still eating a ton
more calories that I was eating instead
of apples and a few things and eating
more stuff like you know quinoa and
adding other things and and I changed it
you know I helped myself I mean and I
did do a lot of reading up on it like
anoraks
stuffin and back then I was really
self-help you know early on in recovery
reading every book I could and I thought
yeah this is this is gonna take me out
like the drugs took me out and just
reading people's stories and books I had
gotten a couple of books and I was just
like yeah I don't well what were the
four I didn't remember the name but it
was a woman
two of them were by women that wrote
about their you know their times of
anorexia and stuff it was in Barnes and
Nobles I just happened to be looking in
uh-huh
got books on eating disorders alright so
you you make this meth sale over the
phone and you get busted and you end up
in jail that was scary
yeah it was just how long were you in
jail for like less than two days but I
was in overnight yeah which I didn't
think the cop told me oh you won't be in
overnight and so when I'm going in and
I'm going through the process and you're
sitting like in a lobby I mean I've
never been to jail so I was just
thinking all bars in this but it was
like the waiting room at the airport or
something huh and this is just from what
I can remember my it was in uh it was a
women's Correctional Facility and
Milpitas so it's called Elmwood and so
in San Jose is where they took the men
to that jail and in Elmwood it was for
the females and so there's a lot of
interesting people in there just me
remember you know here's me all got out
and and just going in through the whole
process and where they strip you down
and just they treat you like [ __ ] I mean
cuz you're a criminal I guess in their
eyes and I'm just like I'm not supposed
to be here
and they're like just get over it you
know and the whole time I'm like well
they're I'm not supposed to be here
they're gonna let me out they should be
letting me out now don't you know who I
think I am yeah exactly
and so even the guy that took my photo
so I worked in a hair salon in downtown
San Jose he was one of my clients so
that was just the guy who worked in the
jail that took your yeah it was just
like oh god you know just so
embarrassing you know to have been going
through this and out here's a person
that knows who I am and knows what I'm
going through and it was a dark time and
so going in like they've hand me the
clothing to put on like after you know
I'm in there for several hours before
they even do that and I'm like no I'm
not supposed to stay and they're like
yeah you're going into whatever with the
rest of the people so you get your
outfit on you're
flops and you know nothing fit it was
like all falling off of me I was so
skinny and March us all in and you know
and I remember the cops telling me he
goes if you do get in there I'll make
sure that they put you in a cell by
yourself so I did end up in a cell by
myself and so when I went into the you
know and I'm crying I'm just like I
don't belong here and I belong here and
there was like it's like a mirror it's
not really a mare it's a piece of sheet
metal you know you don't want you to cut
yourself cut somebody with them breaking
a mirror and so I'm just looking at
myself in this thing and thinking what
am i what am I doing here
how did I get here this is you know my
whole life I'm just thinking oh my god
this is not who I am and so it dawned on
me I need to do something I need to
change so I remember sitting on the bed
and laying down and it's like these
fully blankets in fact they use them at
two hundreds and I won't put those
blankets on me I'm like at the sleep
station I'm like remote that's
interesting this is the same blanket but
my life is them so that I I mean I had a
crew this time so I made my car with my
you know at the sleep stations with my
sleeping bag I know those things freaked
me out and there's times like literally
I'm freaked out like getting that thing
away from me but those are kind of cool
gun shots - because you're like oh this
is it's such a vivid tactile like memory
that takes you back it makes you
remember where so I know what I need to
do not to ever ever be it's like a it's
like a relapse dream yes you're awake
and everything's a relapse dream and
you're awake for a hundred so so you
have this moment you make this decision
and so what was it well yeah you know I
mean was it they assigned me a public
defender so I had to go to court right
away and so I got the charge so they
were gonna charge me with everything my
boyfriend got charged for selling
possession like everything and he kept
trying to take the blame saying no she
had nothing to do with it although I was
the one that sold it on the phone but he
was taking all the blame when they came
in and raided the house and all that he
showed him where we cooperated but he's
like just you know she's never been in
trouble you know he had been in trouble
before and they saw that and the judge
saw that I was talking with my attorney
and he goes
he goes usually that you're gonna charge
the female with the same amount of crime
as their boyfriend or whatever and he
goes but he goes he might be nice to you
and we'll see well you have a job you
have you know you've never been in
trouble so with that he went in front of
them and said you know she has a job
she'll go into drug diversion and she'll
go to meetings and so then he said okay
let's see let's put her into an
outpatient program go to any everyday
either one of them and get the papers
signed and I was checking back every two
weeks and so I was going and this went
on for three months in - six months and
then they finally I was off a drug
diversion after six months with no no
record they let all of that go good so
no felony charge yeah and they didn't
try to roll you into is you know trying
to get somebody above you I try to cut a
deal like no see that's why the the guy
that turned us in he pretended like we
were the bigwigs
we didn't yeah they couldn't do anything
because Jason was gonna tell me where he
got it
so he was fine with going to jail and he
did he had he spent three months in jail
and then three months house house arrest
mm-hmm so and he got his thing wherever
they they wipe your slate clean years
later I mean he's been clean and sober
for all these years - so yeah so
court-ordered - na naa
yep how was that interesting you know I
was in downtown San Jose so there was a
lot of game ex-gang members in my
meetings at that court card sign yeah
but I just was like feeling like I did
nothing you know my what I got arrested
for was nothing compared to what these
people see on a daily basis and how they
were raised and you know but they're in
recovery too and trying to better their
self but I was just like my god I can't
even talk because I don't have I'm just
like this white chick that so much she
got you know she's just hanging out in
the clubs and she got arrested like my
story didn't matter and so did you
but did you embrace or accept the fact
that you were an addict or an alcoholic
or just somebody who got in trouble no
no I knew I was and what's that what's
the what's the relationship between the
meth and the booze like why it's really
really
drinking after I I stopped drinking
pretty much when I started doing math
because you don't really get drunk
anyways when you didn't I'd rather do
the math No unless you want to go to
sleep so then after I did get arrested
I was drinking for a little bit couple
months after that until they were like
no you're not supposed to drink at all
either so that's why I went from the
time I got arrested til June 24th is my
actually sobriety date I'm still
drinking here and there when it went out
on occasion but I wasn't doing drugs and
clean and sober ever since June 24th is
my day but like it's not really your
thing right now you know I and I
appreciate that people that helps them
my brother goes day he's been off and on
for years back and forth into recovery
now he's been in it for a long time and
he it's great tool I would say I think
that's a you know the main thing of
starting my recovery was that but then
going to therapy really helped me more
because I felt like I just had deeper
issues and you know I you know I just
it's hard for me to sit around and just
listen to the same stories over and over
when I would just want to move forward
in life and I like talking about my past
because it helps people but it's like I
have so much more in front of me that
it's like here's what this is what I did
let's keep going you know let's talk
about the future let's talk about good
things we can keep doing you know it's
like when people say I want to do this
that the other but I can't do it and I
you know wait a couple of months and I'm
like no do it now you might not be here
tomorrow no you know so but it
definitely helped me but I just you know
I prefer going into the mountains as my
church praying and just thinking and
that's where I do all my thinking I like
running alone and seeing so much in and
you know I take something away every
time I'm out in the mountains and just
running me on the streets like a bird of
this that and I just am grateful that's
your church that's your pee meeting yep
it is interesting because for me I mean
that's a huge part of my sobriety and my
recovery but for me like that's not
enough like I still like I go to a you
know like I'm part of the recovery
community and and I think now people
sometimes get confused they know my
story and they think like oh well I put
the drugs and the alcohol behind me and
now I'm just gonna train and like that's
so bright and it's like no that
not like at least for me like you only
speaking for myself that's not an that's
I know from firsthand experience that I
need something that I need a more
structured program beyond that that's a
contributing factor that keeps me in
line but for me I need to have a
connection with a higher power I need a
spiritual program I need to be of
service to other alcoholics we're still
sick and all of that you know or or all
go sideways pretty quickly yeah and
thank god I've never wanted to go so
yeah I guess and I look at me now and I
think well that makes perfect sense
because look at how much I get into
something it's like my mind goes and
it's like ain't doing that anymore
that's it but that's very alcoholic you
know that right that ability to focus
it's like harnessing the best of what it
means to be like that kind of human
being and channeling it in the right
direction right I think I think
alcoholics and addicts are look they're
incredibly crafting and focused people
like when you're as you said like when
you're using like your there is no way
you're not gonna find that math that day
yeah no matter what it takes
it's gonna happen right and if you can
take that level of intensity and place
it in a healthy direction then the world
explodes in a good way yep yeah so all
right so you get out you're sober you're
doing the whole deal
when does the running the running
doesn't stop start until two years later
so I I'm you know working out in a gym
I'm getting healthy so I'm doing things
and like I said eating healthy and it
wasn't she when did the vegan did the
vegan thing actually I became a
vegetarian when I was nine we raised
animals so we we didn't know on a farm
so my like cuz that my dad always had
stuff going on so he bought like nine
head of cattle and my sisters were in
FFA which is Future Farmers of America
and I was younger so I was in 4h they
put me in the 4-h program and I had a
lamb and we had the stairs and so before
I ended up getting the lamb we had the
nine had a cattle and then they grew up
and they went away they got sold and
there was one still on the ranch and I
named him Charlie my parents used to
always say don't name those those are
not pets don't name those animals
yeah the more personal
worse and stuff and I was like well his
name's Charlie he's white and he's named
Charlie and that's what I'm calling him
and I'd go up to him and hug him and
whatever so then all the other ones were
gone and Charlie was still there and
then he went away and the day like
within a few days I come home from
school and my brother opens up the
freezer we had a meat freezer in the
garage and he's oh look Charlie's in the
freezer and that was it and that's not
you were not anything and it was
devastating to me when I see it's so
funny I was just at the fair and I saw
these girls like with little lambs and
stuff and I was like oh my god they
don't understand what's gonna happen to
their animal you raised these so yeah
Charlie was in the freezer and I told my
mom I'm not eating anything out of there
I'm not eating a hamburger ever again
and she didn't force me to I mean she
was Italian so she would take the
sausage out or that you know whatever
the meatball and so even though there
was meat sauce and there whatever is a
connection that I had but as long as
there was no meat hamburger like I
didn't eat a hamburger when I went to
McDonald's I would eat fish and chicken
growing up but so then my lamb you know
I was eating lamb still I think until
that point to the following year when I
went to the fair once again had my
little lamb auctioning it off socks I
didn't this boy said to me you know
they're getting some he's gonna eat him
and I was like no they're not and then I
thought oh my god Charlie my lamb
like I thought somebody's just gonna
keep him for a pet like I did you know
it wasn't a connection because I just
thought they agreed on 10 and so I just
went off I just started bawling and I
ran to the pen where he was and I just
laid in there and my dad came and found
me and he's like no no no they're gonna
keep him for a stud and I think you know
I don't know this the real story but I'm
sure my dad told the guy like go tell
her I don't know he came over he goes oh
no no we're gonna keep him first dad and
I was like I don't know what that is
back right so there went lamb so it's so
a young age I was very aware of it off
and I'm very sensitive towards animals
growing up and you know how to duck and
my brother killed my duck and just like
you know he's a wider relationship with
Truman right now
like on a whole other level I love dog
owners yeah super fun that you didn't
bring I know now I'm feeling really bad
I should for people that are listening
or watching well they're probably mad
that I didn't break yeah I'm like worth
I mean your dogs like famous yeah more
so like 12 or 13 now whole is good he's
12 years 7 months so he's going out
there and I've only had him for six and
a half years I rescued it right and what
kind of dog is he he's a dachshund
dachshund and thank you he's run ultra
50k 550 K's
legs nine pounds can run 50k starting at
six and a half hour he started ran his
first 50k at seven yeah and you trained
him like you would train a human right
just start very slow I can't believe a
little dog like that can run a heavy K
there's people emailing me that have
Wiener done you get people angry at you
like this is abuse or what they have but
I have read I mean my doctor my vet is
he's like vet approved and I have
friends that are all trainers that are
vets and they said we are taught and
veterinarian school that these guys have
all these back issues and they're like
we never think they could run because
they have back issues well the back
issue can't happened from running it
happens from jumping and it makes
perfect sense to have them run low to
the ground keeping them thinner and just
getting him checked and it's like he's
just happens to be an amazing little guy
and he has always been fed approved I've
had full-body x-rays I mean it's not
like I'm just some crazy lady letting my
dog run and I knew that people would
come out of the woodwork and try to say
stuff and it's like I got proof I have
vets that approve of him doing this and
now he has gotten older and he has a
heart murmur so we've tapered him back
to 10 miles at the most 10 miles of
tomorrow yeah and with those tiny little
legs I mean if you broke it down by
dried I mean the 50k is probably like a
200 miles whatever deal with that you
put like ski goggles on yes well he's
had I in juries and thousands of dollars
like his surgery on his eyes cuz he's
low to the ground running trails pokey
things
uh-huh are right on the trail I love
also he
had one of his cornea has got really
scratched and he had to have surgery on
it and that's why that usually has
problems and he has eyedrops for the
rest of his life because he doesn't make
tears and so my vets like the best thing
you can do because I swear like every
six months it was like a major eye issue
and the last one was last year tahoe 200
we were sweeping the course mean him
we're pulling the ribbons and he was
with me and I had these trekking poles
and then he had a sharp point and he ran
into the point and scratched his eye
again and it took three months for it to
hell so finally were like okay we got a
got a do you know he started with the
regular little dog of ones that were
individual like glasses and he would
wear them but you he minute you stop
they were off and they were all ruined
and so a friend of mine actually she's
like there's this company called
rexspecs that makes these really cool
goggles but at the time they didn't make
extra small
they were only making small so they were
way too bad for dogs though oh they are
specifically designed for dogs oh yeah
like a lot of because this is a thing
like of course my dog's wear them yeah
it's a thing Truman's the only dog that
I've ever done Eric you know you know
cuz dogs get damaged from the Sun just
like we do that's why here's so many
dogs of having like like coma and he's a
certain thing cataracts
from the Sun and stuff and it makes
sense but like I said he's always gotten
scratched and so these these are so much
better he doesn't have the gunk like oh
it was constantly cleaning gun he wants
him off when he's done so he knows when
they come on like I won't put him on a
road run you know cuz it's like let him
not I have to wear him but definitely on
the trail there's so much debris that
gets in his eyes I do have a leash when
you're running with them or disease so
when we're off trow we don't need to
like on places where you don't need to
have a leash no he's not on leash yeah
on the tram what happens when you have
the occasional like rattlesnake
encounter or he's always behind me so
he's not ever been one to run like way
in front of me so which is good because
most people are like what do you do and
I'm like we've never had that problem
he's like beeline straight towards a nap
rattlesnake when I jumped out of the way
am i drivin and finally like he looked
at me and I was like able to grab him
like he was on us on one on top of one
that was Coral coral
that would have not been good because
he's so little and if he gets bit I mean
there's anti-venom but in the Bay Area
where it was that it was like 40 minutes
away it's for the event for the dogs
it's around here I'm sure you guys have
it yeah that's still I mean we lost a
dog to rattlesnake bites no I know it's
it's it's I mean it's happens but I
think that's totally cool like I
remember it reminds me one time I did
the Alcatraz swim this was like a long
long time ago and the guy the organizer
of it I think it was on New Year's Day
like it did like though you know on the
coldest day or whatever of course but
the organizer at the time if memory
serves me had a black lab and apparently
this black like this this lab his
favorite thing was to do the swim and he
would do the swim from Alcatraz with
everybody and he would beat half the
field and he was so excited like running
around in circles and then he went he
you know swim up onto the beach and run
around and like you know like everybody
like it was like he was like on fire
yeah and who would have thought like
it's supposed to be a la you know these
prisoners could never make it out of
Alcatraz like the dogs like out there
just like beating half of these swimmers
out that's amazing yeah I mean animals
are pretty amazing if they find a
passion and love like we do if they can
do it yeah you know and like said I've
never I've never got to a point where
Truman has laid down and been exhausted
and said I can't go yeah no I mean
granite like if Courtney owned him he
would probably be dead so I'm not like
pushing him like that have you ever been
in a race though where he's like I can't
go anymore and drop out or whatever no
no no no no no he's running ahead in a
race when he gets a bib on and I take
him off leash he's running with the
other runners like in front of me and
they're like wow oh no the wiener dogs
beating us you know that's when he runs
in front of me because he keeps thinking
I'm up there and then he's like oh
that's not her where did she go you know
she kept me so yeah when he see when he
gets a bib on he knows that's a
different thing we're in a race it's so
interesting yeah it's funny all right so
so where does the vegan thing come in so
where do you make that switch so I was
vegetarian already before I got clean
and sober and decided the day that I
quit doing drugs that me and my friend
Katrina were talking about oh we're
gonna go vegan and when when we were on
drugs we have these conversations about
being vegan so so that was the perfect
time I said you know I'm not doing drugs
anymore I'm going vegan so that's when
it all started the same day that pretty
much I quit you know doing drugs I quit
eating me what was that decision about
for you though just to get myself
almost like a purification exactly yeah
like I'm not doing that toxic stuff I'm
gonna get clean and sober and I'm gonna
be good and I'm glad I did that helped
but you know there's unhealthy vegan
there was eating a lot of sugar and crap
that is not so healthy and back then it
was mostly like you didn't have really
almond milk or stuff like that was
mostly soy and I have a major
intolerance with soy like I get major
stomach issues from a lot of soy I can't
do it so I try to avoid that and back
then it was like mostly soy everything
was soy tofu soy and it's like now we're
it's so wonderful we have all this
plant-based you know beyond mean and
like just great like without soy and
gluten and yeah it's come a long way but
it's also easier to be on an unhealthy
vegan with all the crazy you know you
can get all the cupcakes and whatever
you know I got a bunch of pastries
everything ladies breathe they're super
healthy food yeah I love that good so
you do that and then but it's still a
spell before the running so two years so
I'm working out doing my thing at the
gym and I went back to school so I
hadn't ever graduated high school so I
went through the Adult School and I
could have taken your your cosmetologist
at the time like working part time so I
moved back home to the Bay to Fremont
from San Jose uh-huh and working part
time and I decided I wanted to go back
to school and get my high school diploma
like a normal person like sit back in
the classroom so I went through the
adult program I could have taken my GED
and got over it and been out but I
thought now I'm gonna go back like where
I should have been and so I was going to
cosmetologist or just part-time in there
working in a salon part-time and I was
in a Barnes & Noble's and there was a
flyer well actually on a back shot so I
had this other little wiener dog I used
to take for a walk always have cleaner
dogs party chermen
note remember you to him and this was
Oscar Mayer wiener so I was I would take
him on these three-mile walks and one
day I just out of nowhere I don't know
what possessed me but I'm like I'm gonna
run I'm gonna run today I'm gonna go out
for a run and not check him so I went
and I ran my little route three miles
and I was oh I ran you know and that was
really cool so I was in Barnes and
Nobles and there was a flyer in the back
of the store and it there was a fire for
like 5k 10k and I was like I'm you know
that's a 10k I'm gonna run that 10k
finally ran once three miles and I was
in two weeks and I asked my mom I said
do you want to walk the 5k cuz she
walked every day and she's like yeah
I'll go so a couple weeks after I
started running I entered this 10k ran
like no didn't know a pace thought I was
gonna pass out I was stealing like
wearing all black in that phase still
goth phase it was like hot out you have
like the all-black player and like wait
yeah face in the whole black shorts
black sweatshirt and whatever so I
finished and I was like wow you know
that was a big thing and so it got back
to the vehicle and on our car there was
a flyer for the San Francisco Marathon
and I was like when is this and it was
like three months I'm like how far is a
marathon you know as far as like 20
miles and I had to call my friend Kevin
I'm like Kevin do you know if our
marathon eyes and he's like yeah 26
miles 0.2 miles and I said I'm gonna
sign up for it so I sent my check in
because that's like pre anything
computer stuff so I sent it in and I had
three months to change so I trained so I
went into the Barnes and Nobles got a
book that said how to train for a
marathon had to skip ahead to three
months training program and I read that
I was
you know ok Sunday 9 mile run and so
there was no GPS Garmin's none of this I
got in my little car odometer drove four
and a half miles out and it was the gas
station and I was like perfect that's my
turnaround tomorrow and then I'll run
back so that's how I started my training
that the first day nine miles exactly
and just I felt like I was it was you
know I know never knew anybody other
than my dad and my brother that had run
and you know so none of my friends ran
and this was me just doing it for me you
know like finding my own way and so
doing that I was just like wow and like
I said no I didn't know anybody that
Bryan marathons and my family and
friends were like whoa you're crazy you
know but looking back on it now like
what do you think that's which was that
got flicked like what is it about
running that spoke to you I think it was
it gave me confidence and it gave me a
passion something to strive for so and
just I needed something like the stroke
going out to night clubs anymore I mean
you're sober for a couple years yeah I
just felt I assumed you have to change
your friends and yeah that's what saying
I was kind of alone and so running made
me not feel alone like it gave me
something and gave me a purpose uh-huh
and it made me feel good and you
finished that first marathon I did and
it was like I was sore yeah I think
about it we were in the 200 mile races
were like remember how we ran our first
marathon
holy crap like you couldn't walk and it
like after about 200 miles I'm like a
little stiff that day everybody is like
migrate after they finished but it go
take an Epsom salt bath then I come back
to watch the finishers finish several
hours later and I'm like they're like
you don't even look like body's just
like haha and running that marathon I
think I read like you had to run past
all these clubs yeah just a party so I
was running exactly pass all the clubs
and I was just like wow
so each time I passed a place I'm like
look where you are now
yeah that just gave me like this
strength as a propelled myself forward
like look at you now you know it's like
who would have ever thought when you
were in there looking
on the road that you'd be running past
all of this and was there an idea like
this is what I want my life to be about
now or is it just been a natural
progression of becoming more and more I
just knew it was gonna be part of my
life I want to be part of my life yeah
and how did you know that like what was
what what do you think it was even in
the middle of that first marathon I was
planning my next one I hadn't even cut
to this line not even halfway I'm like
haha I think I'll go to Honolulu I want
to do the Honolulu Marathon
yeah that's special because most people
I mean that's unusual yeah that's my
mind though like even like oh I hope
somebody puts on a 500-mile race Candace
you need to come up 500 miles she's
gonna not then no no this is like now
but have you ever heard of ultras like
when did you first discover that so the
first year I ran two marathons and the
second ere I decided I was gonna run
every Marathon in California and this is
mind you not knowing anybody and I
actually started running some of them
were Trail marathons because at the time
in California there was too many to run
I couldn't run them all but a lot of
them were on trials and I thought oh
this is kind of interesting there's you
know these trials that were running on
it was a whole lot harder than running
on a road marathon you the very first
one I did I was like this is way harder
there was no water stop every mile it
was like the guy that put on the trial
marathon that I did for my first one was
in the Marin Headlands and it was like
water every six miles like out of a jug
and box a thing of cookies which I
couldn't eat
I mean they weren't vegan so I was like
oh my god you know and they they told us
in advance you need to carry water
bottles how to buy a waste thing uh-huh
so getting through my first trail
marathon I met actually a guy that it
was running with and he was doing all
the marathons in California and he kind
of became my mentor this older gentleman
and he so we were running a lot of the
same ones together he was much faster
than me but on the trails I could kind
of keep up with him but rode he was
faster yeah and this is like 9999 this
is in 90s that he said okay yeah so then
I started hearing people I was at it was
and I remember this vividly I was at a
it was a marathon in Morgan Hill and I
heard this lady Linda who's actually a
friend of mine now but she was rambling
on that she had run because the
on a Sunday she ran like a fifty-mile or
the day before I was like fifty miles
she ran at fifty miles she's running a
marathon today like and she talks like
she's funny like I've known her all
these years that she was going on and
I'm like how could she be talking like
she's running this marathon today so I
heard her talking about that and then I
thought I'm gonna run a 50k it's only
six miles more I mean come on everybody
trails and it sounds so much more
impressive though so I signed up I found
like a 50k and actually the very first
50k backed that up so I called the race
director because at the time there you
had to it was in the back of like
runner's world or remember there's no
email and all that so there was one in
Fremont called Aloni 50k and this is has
9,000 feet of climbing in it right and I
was like yeah it's in Fremont I'm gonna
run it because I live in Fremont you
know and I had never I think I've been
at Mission Peak a couple of times at
that point a few times and I knew it was
hard but I didn't know what was beyond
that like it was a point-to-point so it
went out to del val and so I called up
the race director and I said oh I want
to sign up for your 50k and he goes have
you run out there before and I said well
I've been at Mission Peak and I'm doing
marathons he goes hmm he goes you know
it's really hard it's really remote and
I said oh yeah and he goes well because
how long have you been running for and I
said a couple of years and he goes and
you want this to be your first 50k and I
was like yeah I want to I've been at
Mission Peak twice and he goes it's a
lot harder than you think and he kind of
scared me and he goes I suggest for you
to run skyline 50k and that was an
easier one at like Shabo and I was like
okay cuz he kind of scared me and he was
like pretty much telling me not to do it
so I was like okay I'll go run that one
so that was and at the time there was
only like I think there was maybe 450
K's in the Bay Area uh-huh now I can't
even tell you a hundreds right and this
is just in the Bay Area I lived I mean
that whole scene had been around for
probably a couple decades but yeah it
was still very much this micro
subculture less people sleeping in tents
the night before and just small groups
of people it was hardly what we think of
yeah everything's a lottery and sells
out now I mean it'll only sells out so I
decided then okay I'll do this 50k so I
did the one at Lake shoe Bowen at that
I had already run I did this - 15 mile
looped course it wasn't part of the
course I mean some of the miles was but
I wanted to feel confident that I can
run 30 miles so I did 30 miles before
even the race came and that was at a
slower pace
I mean race date you're always pushing
harder you know because you're wanting
to get ahead of people and you know you
have nobody to push you when you're by
yourself training and you're just kind
of dealt dilly-dallying so I showed up
it was 105 degrees that day super hot I
was not used to like walking like heels
and I'm seeing all these people like
right off the bat once we got off the
road part it was a steep hill and
they're all walking and I'm thinking oh
heck are they walking and people are
like you should probably walk right now
you know and it's there's lots of hills
and is this your first ultra and I'm
like yeah but I don't need to walk right
so all those people later on of course
passed me and like see you should have
been walking my legs I mean it was so
hot I didn't know about hydration didn't
you know wasn't drinking right wasn't
eating correctly knew nothing and I was
just like by the time I got to like I
think 27 miles I was like oh my god like
in a bad way I'm like am I could even
make it like I was scared I wasn't gonna
make it to the finish because I legs
were so tied and just like you know
dehydrated and so but I made it and I
finished and I was like oh my god that
was so hard and then I was like well I'm
gonna do a 50 mile or so it's just at
that time ultra running magazine was the
magazine so you got I got a copy at the
finish of the 50k so I know anything
about this magazine until I finished and
that's where it opened up it was like
all these races here's where the races
are this is my Bible to see where I'm
gonna go next so I signed up for
50-miler and then I did another 50k and
this is all within a four month period
and I got through this 50-mile race that
was in Napa and it was pouring rain like
horrible [ __ ] I never ran in conditions
like that and they actually allowed you
to drop to the 50k if you wanted to and
you were in the 50-miler
and I stuck it out I said nope I'm gonna
do this and I'm gonna finish this and
then I'm gonna
100 miler so in the middle of it I was
just like oh my god what am i doing if I
can get through this that means I'm
tough enough and I can do this under
miles yeah so I got through the finish
and then decided to run a hundred mile
race and what are you learning about
yourself along the way like what is
running doing for you so I'm learning
that I am I
I never looked at myself as being super
strong or you know confident I was
always you know a little bit I'm not so
confident and what if I can do it or if
I can but my confidence was building and
I was feeling like I can do whatever I
set my mind to and it took me a long
time to learn that in life like I always
would put up blocks and put up doors and
walls in front of me and not you know
just think I couldn't do it right and
then being able to mend not taking that
risk it's like well you're never really
putting yourself on the line exactly and
so and I remember I'm gonna backtrack to
me and my dad were watching when you
know way back in the day they used to
have western states on Wide World of
Sports
do anybody yes and so my dad he was a
runner and he was like come watch this
scene he goes there's these people
running from [ __ ] Valley and I know
where Scott Valley in Auburn were cuz I
used to go play soccer and Auburn and
we'd go to [ __ ] Valley just ski once in
a while or go to the snow and he goes
there running from [ __ ] Valley to
Auburn and I was like yeah you know I
was like 12 or 14 at the time and it was
like okay I sat down and I was like okay
you know I wasn't interested but I
remember that I remember him talking
about this westerns days and he was a
runner like I said he had did a marathon
and I was like hmm whatever you know no
that was my thing okay I'm gonna go give
me some money at the store and he'll
write but it was lodged in the back yeah
so no conscious when I started running
after I did that marathon and then I did
my 50k I was like I gotta do this
hundred mile er like my dad if he was
alive he'd be right here helping me get
do this thing and it you know I had
heard what a hundred mile or was vaguely
just through that one chance you know on
the TV and so I was like I'm gonna do
this so I didn't know anything or
anybody that ran and Anna Harry had
already did my few fifty fifty to fifty
Kay's or 150 K and 250 mile earth and
show up at the Henry Murray
knew nothing didn't even have a light so
me and at the time my boyfriend Kevin
I'm like [ __ ] I gotta go to Walmart or
wherever get a light I need these lights
for night time I wasn't even think
that's how like clueless right clueless
I was a no nighttime running and I was
like okay and at the time I got bike
lights and they had like the bigger
batteries it was dead batteries so I'm
showing up in you know getting all this
new stuff to use and at the time I was
eating a lot of baby food because it's
easy to digest when I was doing altars
and I thought I read up somebody ate
baby food I'm gonna put baby food in my
drop bags and jars of almond butter or
whatever at the time they didn't have a
squeezy packet of baby food it was just
the cans of it right they were jars were
broken at my drop because they're not
very gentle with drop bags so that's
what I used as fuel there was I had
think a gel at the time there was a
couple of shell companies but I in Clif
Bar and that was it and I for the whole
time yeah I didn't know the right
nutrition I hadn't met anybody doing
these hundreds and 50 miles really to be
able to figure this out well it's the
trajectory is pretty traditional like
okay
10k marathon 50k 50-miler and then it's
like okay 100 miler like the jump from
50 mile or 100 mile like people think of
those as being kind of in the same world
but those are I mean you're doubling the
distance you know it's like it's a crazy
leap and it's a very different thing
doing a hundred is 50 that's what I mean
back then there wasn't a lot of hundred
K's so there there are hundred caves
around but back then there was like
maybe four to five in the United States
so you had to go that leap that was your
leap there was no like in between like
they do now and what is tell me the
difference it's a big difference
I mean past fifty miles then you're like
you're dealing with going into the night
if you haven't trained at night you're
going into like you know hallucinations
I mean not sleeping trying to keep
yourself awake it's a whole nother
you're stumbling around and knowing when
to walk yeah breaks I was like soaked I
was so out of it back then I wouldn't
even I wasn't even doing coffee back
then I thought that was a drug so so in
the middle of nighttime
Tumlin around and this lady comes up on
me she goes are you okay and I said no
I'm tired and I said I I said I hope
there's coffee at the next aid station I
was gonna willing to have coffee and she
goes okay she goes I don't think they
have it here and she goes you need to
take it like a caffeine pill and I'm
like what's that she goes it's just like
coffee and I'm like no that's like a
drug that's like speed and she goes no
it's just like it's 200 milligrams of
caffeine so this me and her we're going
on and on and we were walking together
her name was Kim and we got to the aid
station and they actually had no coffee
and I was like oh my god how many did do
this and I was like bad falling asleep
like I I didn't know how I was gonna get
even around this but this was like my
house I was going into my lady loop 80
to 100 no I was at Mile 60 so I was
already going into getting to 80 and I
could not stay awake so she convinced me
to take this caffeine pill and she goes
break it in half if you're that freaked
out about that she goes you really need
to take it you're not gonna make it and
she was right I took this caffeine pill
100 milligrams and all of a sudden it
was like wow I'm like awake and I didn't
do coffee back then so so you're - yes
so I it definitely helped me that saved
me I probably would have never been able
to finish I mean it was so out of it and
just taking that little bit of caffeine
got me through that through that night
you know and I was like okay it's not
that bad but it was years before then
that I even did coffee I didn't start
drinking coffee into like 2004 yeah you
don't seem like you need it no I had
some today do you have have you dnf'd a
bunch of Rice's
you do that with that's how you Laura I
mean you race all the time you ever like
you're just constantly like it's been a
constant stream of you racing ever since
right like a lot yeah like after this
doing these three 200 unjustly and I
want to do anything but I have a
hundred-mile are coming up like next
weekend and do you treat every race the
same or do you try to peak for certain
races or prioritize certain events well
obviously with the 200 you were just I
was just like there was no training I
was like you know you're racing and then
going for it and that's a different kind
of race you're you know you're taking a
slower to be able to survive and then
push yourself later on I was think in
between
the most important thing is making sure
they're healthy and right back up
because I like with I started I think I
was like 113 1 6 14 at the beginning of
the race season I mean I always get down
to about 109 110 if I'm doing lots of
races but I got down to like a hundred
and three and hundred and four and was
constantly trying to add you know
calories like I mean like jars of almond
but everything else I'm like eating
vegan ice cream which I never hardly eat
but I know I'm needing calories and so
I'm like buying one for me and one for
my boyfriend my boyfriend's like somehow
[ __ ] this is not going right you're not
gaining weight I'm gaining weight so but
just eating a ton of healthy and lots
more calories like I said adding more
nuts and high calorie stuff every day
just to gain that weight so you know
you're going to lose it when you're back
into the game and a typical training
week is what like 80 to 120 miles yeah
in the summers I'm definitely up there I
mean so this year I try twice a day or
not some of my runs I mean I had some
300 something mile weeks this year do
you work with a coach or design your own
just do it just do your way yeah I like
training and my whole thing is I love
just being outdoors and being in the
wilderness and you know I was fast at
one time I'm not ever gonna be as fast
as I can you know I guess if I had a
coach but I run because I love it I
don't that's the thing I like you just
like being at these races and you like
being part of the community myself when
I'm in a race I'm like training for me
it's just enjoying the earth and seeing
what I can see because you know I been
given a gift I feel like it's a gift to
be able to do this cuz I'm no different
than anybody else and it's like I just
happen to have this love for being
outdoors now and that's you know seeing
things every day I don't want to miss
anything you know one day I'm not gonna
be here or I can't do it and I know that
time can come I could hurt myself I
could something can happen where I can't
run again and so I'm enjoying it now
uh-huh
injury-free you've never had any just
like minor stuff like PF here and there
my
always had a hamstring thing and I heard
that in CrossFit years ago and it just
comes and goes and I you know I have
recovery pump boots and I go to you know
get massages and so Epsom salt baths so
I'm constantly doing stuff that helps me
massages acupuncture you have everybody
back issues are now ya know I'm starting
to get more like a shoulder thing just
from with your head down and you're in
the 200s and you're fine you know it's
like notice that the older I get and the
longer I go it it bothers me so now I
don't even try to carry the bladder
bottles in my hands in the 200s because
I'm using trekking poles anyways I put
the water's up here for my hydration and
I find that that actually helps me when
I'm using the trekking poles in the
200-mile race I usually don't drop on to
them till about 50 miles in but they
give you something to do and then you're
working your other muscles so you're not
like and outside the running what kind
of cross-training do you do I do I lift
weights oh I do kettlebells box jobs
kind of like modified CrossFit stuff
yeah but on my own and so in Bishop I
haven't been working out I mean in a gym
for two months and I used to go to
24-hour fitness or whatever and I'm like
I don't have a lot of options at Bishop
but I found that they have a CrossFit
that actually is open 24/7 and they have
other stuff in there you can use the
they have great treadmills and rowing
machines and weights that you can use so
you don't have to just do CrossFit and
that's kind of what right I'm gonna join
that so you show up on the pages of Born
to Run I would imagine that kind of
changed your life a little bit I mean
that book was such a big deal and they
still they've been trying to make a
movie out of that forever that's ever
gonna happen it looked like it might
have might it looked like it was gonna
go Peter Sarsgaard was but I don't know
what happened but but so many people
read that book and and that was really
an entry point for most people's unless
you read Dean Karnazes book I mean this
was an entry point for people to
discover what this whole ultra running
world was all about and you were this
crazy colorful figure I mean so what was
that like for you and how did that
change you know what would happen to you
when you would show up at these races or
just how you were living your life I
would meet a lot of people because the
people were not right
and then they became runners because of
this robot so many people that they may
have been 10k runners or not runners at
all and they read this and they had this
whole thing where they wanted to get
into this barefoot running and that's
right but that kind of is not the thing
but they're all minimalist getting into
it I'm like yeah I don't you know people
were coming up to me and they were like
you're that girl in the book and I'm
like yep that's me I'm trying to
remember because you went down for the
race with the Tarahumara in the copper
no no this is all I was at bad water was
so long since everybody's all do you
mind if I write about your yo-yo no go
ahead
uh-huh so you did the yo-yo did you did
you ever get tempted to do the double
bad water no I did bad water so
everybody assumed I did bad water a
bunch of times I did it last year yeah
oh just last year so my boyfriend has
done it three times and I've crewed
there a bunch and I always told Chris
the race director I'm not gonna run it I
don't run on the red road I'm not a road
runner I'm not a road runner and he'd
always see me doing like flatter stuff
and he'd be like uh wait you just did
this or you just did that he was always
trying to encourage me to do it and then
I was like no no no and then finally it
was like guess what I'm gonna do it so I
did his whole series so he has the cape
fair which is the 50-mile and the desert
in are not desert on the beach in North
Carolina and then I did the Salton Sea
which is a team race and then it bad
water right so it's called the alter Cup
so did that last year and bad water is
back to its original course right the
only one year did they not have it they
had lost their nonsense to do start
times different they don't start and
that's right they used to they start at
night which is great it's much better I
think it's much easier because I've
crewed when it used to be the old time
and it's much harder oh yeah I create
China crude for Dean there a couple
years ago and at like 2:00 in the
afternoon you're like what is happening
right now like when you're training no
even when I've crude there I've always
trained you know ready for it but when I
got in I definitely trained like you
know
full-on clothing out in the heat of the
day and I had new problems it was fine
no job yeah I want to go back cuz I
think I could push harder so did you did
your souls melt and not hold
do you know Shannon for our grief unless
of course she was here I say no and she
was playing into me man I'm here at
everything fighting she's here she kick
I know we don't have time she's amazing
yeah she's been able to do and of course
you know she's she's bad I challenge you
no need for our race and it was the same
year she did her first hundred mile er
uh-huh we know each other yeah I just
know a lot of time with her she's
supposed to be a javelina this weekend
but she's with her knee keeps showing up
you guys are the oh jeez yeah so now
when you show up you're like a celebrity
at these races yeah it's interesting but
it's great I mean with the book it's
like so many people are coming up to me
and just saying how it touched them or
inspired them and emails all the time
and you know and that's why I keep going
it's like you know women are oh I'm too
old it's like no you're my age why are
you too old to do this you're not too
old to do anything it's like you could
do anything you want at any age and a
lot of women are just starting to run in
their 50s mm-hmm so it's like it gives
them somebody to look at and you've been
doing this for a long time and some of
your biggest accomplishments are recent
yeah you know I've always done crazy
stuff man oh and the book came out in
March May like this way
yeah a reborn on the run yeah so Tom I
haven't read the book yet but tell me I
mean we're talking about all this stuff
that I know is in the book it's an
autobiography but what inspired you to
write a book about all of this I have so
many stories so like I'd be out on runs
with people and they're like why don't
you write a book why don't you write a
book you know it was a constant thing
and so a literary agent from New York
chrome an agency contacted me and they
said have you thought of writing a book
and I said yeah but I don't have time to
write a book I could record a book and
then somebody could put it on paper for
me I'm busy running all the time so they
said well we can help you do this and so
I said all right and say this guy Dan
had written an article about me and I
really liked the style he came and
following me he did all this research on
me and so he knew me really well and I
said well do I have to use one of your
writers or Kuwait used somebody else and
she said well you certainly can Iris
else you can hire somebody she goes but
tell me who you want and I'll contact
them and have a chat with them and so I
said here's the person and here's this
contact and they contacted him and then
he got back to me and I he was yeah he
was I've never written a book he goes I
write he writes for a newspaper and he's
great at interviewing so we decided that
we would collaborate and we would work
together and he'd be my writer so we
figured out the way we were gonna do it
I was gonna record my stories we came up
with like the format of the book and
then we would record like stories like
the chapters and so in the beginning we
kind of started and we sent a set of it
some of it out and they're like notice
like an interview you guys are like
interviewing each other back and forth
so he was like you've got a really
fleshed detail out so I would go out on
these runs and record you know run walk
and record my whole story that I was
talking about and and I would have to go
back and I wouldn't even stop on the
trail and just sit down and close my
eyes when I was you know recording my
chapter just remembering in full detail
things and so that's how he did it
I recorded it basically and we you know
by chapter by chapter and it was a lot
of work it wasn't easy
uh-huh and so that's how he did it
that's cool really cool yeah so you've
so congratulations thank you yeah it's
no small thing so you've been kind of
touring around yeah do book signings and
you know a lot of my races I'm just
doing book signings I'm you know and
different like I'm gonna be in San Diego
in December at running skirts to do a
thing with them and I did a bunch of the
re eyes in the Bay Area so I'm waiting
till after the new year to start doing
more stuff cuz it's like I'm after all
the running just doing all those races
I'm like I just want to have a me time
and be on the trail all by myself it's a
weird thing like you're your story's so
different than mine but like and ultras
I'm in recovery I vegan you know like
what is it about I mean I need to get
some tattoos I guess that's my next
venture I suppose but what do you think
it is about like those three things that
I mean there's so many like there's a
lot of vegans in the ultra world like I
feel like that's the sport that really
launched the idea that you could be an
athlete and be vegan now
you seeing athletes and all different
disciplines but exactly started in this
ultra world maybe that's because of
Scott Jurek I don't know but and I was
around before him right so but no but
you know I wasn't fast or you know and
that he got us on the map you know
you're the vegans and you know like I
said I'd been vegan for a long time and
it shows you look I'm not I didn't waste
away I'm still going by getting enough
protein I've been I mean you're 53 and
you just rent three two hundred mile
plus races in a period of ten weeks yeah
and so what we can't do anything yeah
you look amazing so it's all working
fine yeah and and I'm so happy with them
you know with the social media is
showing these other athletes that you
see these even raw vegan bodybuilders
and it's like no I do you have to eat me
look at this guy you look at them and
obviously they know what they're doing
you're you're getting the right amount
of calories and food and building your
body from there mm-hmm so it's not yeah
it's sad I wish everybody could kind of
get on board it's changing you know it's
really you know awareness and I think
social medias played a big party which
is really good you know the
documentaries and stuff and it's
changing and people get angry but then
there there's a conversation that's
happening exactly so there's a there's a
debate that's often healthy sometimes
not health Mia and I think a lot of
times when people are like overweight
they're like oh I don't that's not good
for you it's because they're afraid you
know they have to face their self and it
was funny because I was running with a a
guy at the race and he was like most men
that become vegan they were overweight
or something and then they watch a
documentary and and they get back in you
know they can get into this it's like
more women tend to be going into the
veganism but guys are like meat and you
know you're supposed to be the hunter
kind of thing and and they well there's
different entry points for different
people yeah I think a lot of guys yeah
they reach middle age and they feel
lousy and they're overweight I mean
that's my story and then I'm like I need
to do something different and now 12
years later it's like about the
environment you know factory farming and
it's about exactly and actually we're a
turn-off at that time like yeah a lot of
it is timing people have to be in the
right place in their life at the right
time in order to receive a certain
message you know I certainly would not
have been able to hear it you know a
year prior to where I was and so you
know I think everybody has a role in how
they advocate you know these lifestyle
choices and I think they're all
appropriate because people are tuning
into different frequencies yeah I agree
with you a lot of people start as a diet
and then their their mindset they're
like wait and it goes a little further
and then you're more conscious of what's
going on in the environment and they
start just using it as a diet not really
as a lifestyle because it is a lifestyle
change but then it expands you got you
you you know it's like you ran a 10k and
now you're the ultra queen diva
what does that even mean what is that
alright because in that explain how an
ultras you you get these nicknames well
that's not that's not fast packing and
hiking so so when you're doing like the
Appalachian Trail Pacific Crest Trail
Continental Divide all long-distance
hikers they don't use their real name
you become somebody else
it's just the things with tradition so I
wasn't even doing a long trial I was
doing the yo-yo on the JMT and I met a
guy that was hiking the Pacific Crest
Trail and I came running up the trial
and he was like you know as filthy it
was like I'm I turn around and he goes
do you look like a diva you know it was
like colorful and but filthy I didn't
showered in days you know I'm going on
like ten days and he goes you look like
a dirty diva and I was like and he goes
do you have a trail name and I said no
he goes dirty d-mat I said I don't like
that and he goes
dirty vet and I go oh I like that and so
then we start talking in a new Kimmie's
trail name and you told me you second
the Pacific Crest Trail and I was like
yeah I want to do that one day and so
that kind of stuck so I use that as my
trail name because he gave it to me
uh-huh so that gets kind of how it's
stuck and you've always had the flair
for the color and all that he was like
for people that are just listening to
this on audio it's like you've got I
don't know how many colors in your hair
right now you're wearing like six super
cool and you're known for showing up
these races and you always have these
these like amazing outfits usually
running a skirt you're like there's like
eight hundred colors to you rainbows and
unless you have your own full line of
your gear I do I want to love to know I
am sponsored by people then I would love
to make my own they should well whoever
sponsored you should let you design okay
yeah I agree yeah if they're listening
you know yeah I just love color color
brings joy and happiness I think and I
was in such a dark place for so long and
even people in races they said if you
can just stay there and run right in
front of me this whole race I'm gonna
finish because I'm gonna be feeling good
and happy because you you know just
seeing you in a race people will say
that you came up at the right time I was
like feeling sad and you are just you
look happy you're just happiness but
yeah you're always jumping up and down
and smiling and and like does it but you
must have your dark nominal I was
telling somebody into 200 I'm like [ __ ]
like maybe a mountain lion will bite my
leg you don't have to stop so I don't
have to quit like make an excuse just
like just maybe something will happen
and I have to save somebody's life and
I'll be able to stop the race I mean you
go your mind is like wacko out there you
know and that's what I think but then I
go no knock it off
yeah just keep going don't think that so
I always try to change that bit there's
those points when you're like I gotta be
out here three more days three days with
no more sleep you know sleeping here or
there it's freezing out I was wearing
two pairs of pants at the last race a
polar tech shirt - puffy jackets - with
hoods over my head with a hat with two
pairs of gloves and Hammer this is a
throw up that's so cold animatic thing
up over my face that is how cold I was a
night and I was just okay if I kept
moving like if I had to stop it would
have been way it would have been a bad
thing whatever like it was that bad snow
but I feel like your thing is you're
having fun all the time like you're
doing this for fun you're not here like
I'm gonna beat these people and I'm
gonna be on a podium like you're there
for the ride I'm there to inspire other
people that's what I I would say you
know it's like we need more people to
inspire other people I mean people are
inspired by really fast people but just
me I'm average you didn't just been
doing it and just do crazy things
because I say I want to do something and
I make
you know you're not great well I guess
not done things knowing don't know it's
done and you have plenty of victories
but it's funny because you like you've
won races and you've done things that no
one has ever done before
but you're also like you can be in
middle of the pack or person as well and
be there with you know all kinds of
people who if I finished last I don't
care as long as I finish and to me I
would look at that person they were you
know the last place people were like 12
hours behind me and Moab but it's like
those are the people they're out there a
long time and so yeah they get through
it too so it's all up here that's murder
because imagine being out there for like
a full day long it's like you see that
you see that at bad water yeah I like
you finish and then you go back down the
mountain and you're in the hotel and
then you go to dinner and then you go to
sleep and wake up the next morning
before still coming unbelievable it's
true yeah and that takes an extra level
of like tenacity and focus and you know
I don't know it's it's it's inspiring it
is well you look at Shannon I mean one
year she like I was like is she even
gonna make it like two years ago it was
like questionable and it was like dang
you know I was like two or three girls
go when she finished last and she made
it it's like wow yeah so you've been in
this game for a long time and the whole
subculture and world of ultras has
changed so dramatically I would imagine
there's a hardcore group of people who
lament these changes and want it to
dissolve the way that it was yeah like
go back to the tent and all of that and
yet now it's become I don't know if it's
fair to say mass participatory but the
number yeah and and more and more people
are doing it so how do you think about
that growth I like it I you know a lot
of the old school guys are I was talking
to somebody last week at the race and he
was like well I'm sure many people
that's where I'm running the to hundreds
well yeah if you want to be in a race
where there's less people you do the to
hundreds that's more on the edge now
that's the French people to how these
people are showing up at the 200s so
let's see that race had 100
and I want to say like 180 and it did
sell out sold out how it was like 200
something it sold out and how many
people DNF it's a high finishing rate
all the to hundreds 80% finishing right
how are they vetting people for that or
woody why do you think that is because
you get more time the cut-offs are not
tight because she's allowing for sleep
in the race so it's not a stage race but
it's like a stage drink because it's a
continuous clock running and there is
plenty of time so like the earlier
cut-offs
well this race it just seemed like
because it's longer that the you know
you get more extended but I think the
first cutoff at Mile 30 or no it was
like 20 you because it's so remote she
can't doesn't have a lot of cut-offs in
between because you can't get the people
out of there so you just keep going but
they're the first cutoff you had to get
to 20 miles he had 13 hours which is
right totally do it she makes it so it's
like two-and-a-half miles an hour to
three and that allows for sleep so you
could sleep every day for five hours if
you wanted right and still finish that
would be like at the back of the Packer
was doing it so what does the sleep look
like at the front of the pack morning
nothing she takes like two hour nap
breaks on a 2 minute nap breaks on the
20 minutes she was that she was telling
me that that's how I go how much did you
sleep because I go I only got two hours
sleep and I still took 90 hours to
finish you know because I was wobbling
and just sitting down a lot at the aid
stations and eating and just like trying
to get myself to go cuz I wanted to
sleep but I couldn't and she goes oh I
probably slept about I think she said 12
minutes talking about 12 so like 6 2
minute naps or something like that I had
2 hours which was not enough I try to
have 5 hours total and 200 in the first
two of the Triple Crown I only got 2
hours in and it was the hallucinations
were yeah what are you seeing when
you're hallucinating
everything's is something a tree is
people you know it's just like a stick
as a snake and it's like is it happened
during the day too or only at night you
stay in the day but mostly at night and
then you hear I was getting audio stuff
and it was like huh nobody's around
there's people around me
they're not here and at the end it was
just like everything was at the end of
Bigfoot that was the first time where I
didn't get at least three four or five
hours sleep and race and the walls were
like every rock was a painting like
somebody came out and like I was like
wow these people came out in this little
town and they painted each Rock with
like a picture of mural I was like this
is really cool and I would just be
stumbling and falling asleep on my feet
and so at the end I told my boyfriend he
paced me in and I said did you see that
like killer rock wall and a song what
because there was no rock he goes there
was rock wall I go no there was like all
the the paintings on it because there's
no paintings I said tomorrow you need to
drive me back over there we get there
the next day and I'm like yeah and at
Tahoe I kept so Truman was crewing he
was on the crew at Tahoe with my 8
Pacers and at the end I was so out of it
I kept stopping and I would stop at a
bush and start petting it and I was like
a stream in and I'm like doing it I'd
snap out of it like knowing that what
are you doing you're wondering to these
bushes petting bushes that my pacer was
in front of me and she calls me sister
she's from Mexico my friend Gabby a
pacer I've got water with this shirt she
goes sister what are you doing and I'm
like nothing
and she's like okay I keep coming and
then at bad water she had hallucinations
and we had to push her hard cuz she
barely she was nearly cut off and she
kept saying I see a [ __ ] in a
Chinese pointy hat and so I kept going
to the bushes at one point she goes what
are you doing sister and I said I don't
see a [ __ ] with a Chinese hat
laughter loses he should do a book call
the hallucinations they should look into
somebody's collective I mean after Moab
everybody has like a story crazy stories
like I saw sculptures of mountain lions
out there out of the snow I mean it was
just crazy the people that can't be good
for you but no and one of the women that
was like I think she was in like second
or third van and she was doing the
Triple Crown to fawn and she had
like major loose nation where she laid
down and stopped and everything was
moving she wasn't trapped in this other
world she said it the race director had
to come find her cuz we're all wearing
spot devices in order to send a search
and rescue out they couldn't get to us
in time and so the race director Candice
she always heads up a team like okay we
know that's fun and she hasn't moved for
seven hours we um I gotta go to her I
got to find out what's going on and so
she went out to her and she was said she
was trapped she couldn't get going she
was in like this another world she was
so out of it she hadn't slept Wow so
yeah that's why I try to sleep a little
bit because I don't want to be there I
got yeah good I would imagine it pays
dividend force herself to sleep is what
she does and what happened is she went
to lay down on the trail and she sat her
light down and she couldn't find it in
her gloves and it was freezing out there
so she couldn't move she just she would
see headlights go by and she was trying
to say stuff and couldn't get it out to
people like they were not that far away
from her but nobody saw it was was dark
right so Wow yeah that's craziness so
what's driving all of this like what is
it what what keeps you in it like you've
done hundreds of these things like why
are how are you still enthusiastic about
it what are you trying to learn about
yourself or prove to yourself or is it
just I just want to keep challenging
myself as long as I can because I I know
I'm only here for this one time in my
life and it's like I just enjoy being
out there I just enjoy the whole thing
and the people you meet along the way
it's like you're a family especially in
the 200s you got to help each other you
connect if you don't have Pacers or crew
at night you're like hooking up with
another runner for safety purposes just
keeping each other motivated and you
learn everybody's story out there it's
like we all have a story and it's really
cool to share these things what do you
think people don't understand about
hundreds and to hundreds and these crazy
ultra races they just think it's way too
far and that people can't do that
that's just like you know it's unheard
of they don't believe that we can do
this and they just think you're lying or
yeah they just think we're nuts uh-huh
you know and and it's getting more
common especially now with the hundreds
to hundreds are still a little bit out
there yeah but I'm trying to bring it
but in anybody could do it 200 it's
easier than anybody can do it to your
honor I swear to God it's easier than a
hundred and this is why because it's a
trek time yeah so you get so much more
time to finish and it's doable and
that's why the finishing rate is high
you could push yourself you know first
one go out and see how you do but it's a
matter of managing your sleep and
managing your fuel because you're alone
out there
and you got to be taking care of
yourself so you can't have a problem you
you got 20 miles and could take ten
hours to get into the next aid station
you better be damn well ready to take
care of yourself I think people would be
surprised at the sort of type of person
that shows up at these races because I
think if you don't know better you
imagine or you project this image of
this super athlete and there are
certainly those kinds of people but in
my experience a lot of the people you're
like well like you they just look like
average everyday people they don't they
don't even necessarily look athletic
like I just did a podcast with this guy
Sanjay Rawal who made this documentary
about the 3,100 self-transcendence right
yeah I love this where they go around
the half mile there's like 25 of them or
whatever every year and they literally
run from 6:00 a.m. to midnight every day
for like 52 days in a row until they've
whoever gets to 3100 miles first wins
literally around a city block like the
most importand then they switch
directions each day or something like
that and you look at these people and
you're like you would never think like
they could do some tonight yeah yeah
yeah and they do and it makes you it
really reframes how you think about
sport and performance and extraordinary
accomplished
it's a it's a mind thing like there you
have to have a strong line to do a lot
of this and how have you trained your
mind like what is what is your
relationship with your mind because it
is so mental like how have you gotten to
this place where you can push through
and do these positive thinking and
thinking of others that are not here or
people that are injured or wanting to
change places you know there's people
out there that are sick that have cancer
people right now and they would they
would trade in an instant
to go out and do the triple crown and
have me have their cancer you know what
I mean it's like you got to do it for
other people in and you know just do it
for everybody that can't and that's my
baby so do you take wake up you have
like a mental image of an individual
like when you hit that breaking point
you don't want to keep going what gets
you through yeah a lot of times I run
for people and a friend Dennis O'Connor
just passed away and I saw him recently
at Tahoe and he was out on a training
run I believe he was in France or the
Alps somewhere just out on business and
he was out on a run and there was I
guess the storm I don't know the full
thing you know I just from what I read
online and he fell and he broke his arm
and he didn't have a spot device video
out his phone and he was able to send
like a message and know the
search-and-rescue couldn't come out to
him the storm was too bad so they found
him a few days later dead so stuff like
that I'm like he was doing what he loved
he was everybody loved him in the Bay
Area running community anybody they met
super nice guy and so during you know
the last 200 I just said I'm doing this
for Dennis dennis is with me and we're
you know he's not here anymore to do it
and there's no complaining for me I'm
doing what I love and he did what he
loved it did it about till the end but
just still sad way to go to be by
yourself and right you know so from
hypothermia or whatever he passed away
because nobody could get colonel yeah so
when you think of like the Triple Crown
200 thing that you just did or the
double John Muir or whatever that's
called like how do you like what does it
mean to you just you know just showing
other women it's a lot about me
inspiring other women to do things that
they think they couldn't do and I was
always afraid to even be out in the
wilderness when I first started running
I was like there's no way I would be out
running on a training run going past a
certain point into the mountain and now
it's like I'll just go wherever I want a
carry spot device safety you know where
I live there's the spot devices like a
GPS beacon and I can hit the button if
something happens and it alerts yeah and
it goes right to my boyfriend to
directly see his phone when I hit that
button
then it goes to the search-and-rescue as
well that means I ain't coming out
anywhere but we're gonna get a satellite
phone so that way if I'm ever out on a
run to let him know like okay I'm gonna
be three hours behind I got stuck in a
storm over here and I can't get over the
past yeah but I'm not needing a rescue
so I don't need to push that other
button but we're because he had an
accident in another nurse and he didn't
have a spot device he broke his pelvis
in five places seven months ago out on a
training run and he was taking pictures
standing on a Ledge the rock came down
he was going headfirst he was able to
twist his body around landed on his
pelvis and his phone was still up above
him he had a crawl to get his phone he
had no reception he had to crawl he
didn't know how far he was gonna have to
go that's fine me didn't know how far
when she broke define service to get
service yes so he had a crawl one-mile
took them for hours it was getting dark
it was in February he had no gear to get
through the night and had he not been
calm and relaxed like that's kind of
person he is he could have died out
there but he was able to get reception
luckily you know there was for whatever
reason he got a little bit of reception
able to call he called his work first
because he's supposed to be flying that
plane that flies people I guess he's
supposed to be the guy rescuing himself
so he called and he was like got it he
goes we're I'm sending SAR where you
know he was able to tell me where he was
at and so the search-and-rescue came out
to him then and it still took him a
while to it was another six miles to get
him to the ambulance whoa so he was that
far away from the vehicle that he would
have not made it there was no he said he
couldn't it made it pretty much any
farther than he did he was just trying
to remain calm and knew he was in a bad
situation but you just had it you know
and he was basically scooting me like
four foot one mile four hours scooting
in you but like trying to not do
anything to one side of you uh-huh
so and so they were able to take him to
the hospital x-rayed him and then they
really yeah we're gonna put you in our
put you in your play and the hippos be
flying in to fly you to Reno to have
surgery so now he's got a spot device
yes it's like ironic but he's the guy
who should know more than anybody how
important that is but it's like it's
like a lawyer being a zonad yeah
and you know it's like he didn't really
know and we didn't think you know he had
just moved to Bishop and it's like oh
yeah we don't and I wasn't even around I
was in I was in Texas pacing at a
hundred mile race and then I get this
rambling message oh I tried to base jump
off of a mountain and I fell and I broke
my pelvis that's what I got and he
that's the message he left me because
I'm at the hospital
click love you it was like and I like
Conor man what are you talking about
well he had no hardly any reception back
on it's funny because I'm having surgery
and I'm like wait wait what's happening
what's happening
but he's just that kind of guy like
don't worry about I'm cool yeah mattress
super-dangerous t IV are you familiar
with what's been going on at Malibu
Creek here there's like there was there
was a murderer and there's been a bunch
of break-ins around here and they've
just apprehended a guy who they're
calling the Malibu State Park
survivalist or something like that but
there's like a guy's been living out
like the bigs
I don't you've probably yeah I was just
running there this morning that's the
local that's where I go there was like a
dad and his child who were camping in
there like I don't know eight or nine
months ago who got shot point-blank and
there's been a couple other weird things
that have happened around here like like
a dead body discovered by the Hindu
temple and they don't know if these
things are related yeah and then a bunch
of break-ins around here where nothing's
stolen but they can tell somebody you
know forced forced entry but the food's
like they've eaten all the food yeah so
it's like Oh somebody's living in the
woods right yeah so they just there's
been like this manhunt yeah like just
like two weeks ago there were like
twelve cop cars and like those armored
tank like military LAPD vehicles and the
helicopters and they found this guy I
don't know that they've been able to
legitimately
true that he's the guy behind all of
this but some guys been living back out
in I mean there's so much land there's
got to be people like that all over the
place yeah there's like these people off
the grid that are doing
I mean they can't go way up in the
mountains in the winter because it's
snowing but they can come in and around
town there's so many off-road vehicle
trails and Bishop like I can run for
days I mean we're working on picking
maybe a 200 mile loop down there - oh
really like making your own trail no I'm
talking the racetrack to a race out
there what would you call it it's
tremendous well I love the fact that
that you are this like strong you know
presence and and source of strength for
so many women you know I think it's
super important and your story is like
crazy cinematic it's like oh you're
working in a beauty parlor and you're
not an athlete and you got all these
tattoos you crazy hair and you're goth
never had done anything and now you're
like you just crush it you know and you
continue to crush it and you show up and
you show up and you show up and it's
just I think it's the I think what
speaks to me more than anything is like
the spirit in which you do it like
you're just you're full of like good
energy and happiness yeah and I look
back though and people are like would
you change anything and I said no
because I wouldn't be Who I am today had
and had I not had to go through any of
those experienced darkness is get a drug
yeah it's like I wouldn't be sitting
right here in front of you had I not
been all of those things yeah so when
people I'm sure people email you or get
in touch with you and say I can't get
off drugs or I'm trying to get sober
you're inspiring me like what do you
what do you usually try to share with
those people yeah of course try to tell
them go to AAA I know right off the bat
that I'm not a therapist that I just you
know I just say if you just you know
believe in yourself and start exercising
start eating right you you can do it you
know and it's like
sure enough months later people will
message me back and say thank you for
just even saying anything to me because
I didn't think you were gonna message me
back and I get that all the time I'm
like why wouldn't I message you back I
mean I'm you get a lot of emails I get a
lot of emails but I always try to at
least give them a sentence of a post
because that one person you could be
changing their life and I learned that
long time ago that I'm like I need to
reason especially those ones where
you're like ooh there's there's you know
reaching out to me and I need to say
something cuz who knows who they're not
read yeah and I find often that it's
it's not necessarily about the
information it's like yeah uh like you
need to come to a meeting or you need to
raise your hand and ask for help or you
need to see a shrink or you need to like
I think most people already know that
yeah but it's they want they're like
there they are raising their hand to you
sir and it's the connection it's the
sense that they're being heard and
they're being recognized I think that is
the most important thing I agree with
you and that I think can be
transformative for people right sure I
think this is a really boring question
but I'm gonna get you old if I don't ask
it which is take me through a day in
food like what how do you how do you do
all this stuff and do it on a vegan diet
what are you eating what are you eating
typical day what are you eating when
you're true you know what do you eat
what do you bring with you when you're
training and like how do you fuel on
these races so usually like morning it's
either like I usually do like a smoothie
or do some yogurt with cannoli on it and
just like the Born to Run thing yeah
exactly explain what that is reveal that
don't know so it's what is it it's what
they eat the Tarahumara in the Copper
Canyon in Mexico and so it's just a
grain that they use that has all this
protein and suppose have all these
vitamins in it and it tastes actually
good and I like adding it to my yogurt
just to add some more flavor and maybe a
little protein and usually that's all
have in the morning and a lot of times I
don't even eat before I run in the
morning if I'm just going out for a
short run until I come back like at
11:00 I'm not a big breakfast person and
then I'll have like for lunch
I'll just take like a beyond meat burger
patty and a bowl of fruit and just eat
the patty by itself and then some fruit
and then for dinners my main meal so I
just do like a big salad with a
hodgepodge of everything in it you know
some you know beyond meat burger you
know I use like sriracha vegan Mayo you
like spicy
you know and just every vegetable and I
do a lot of cauliflower rice I like that
yeah that's one of my favorite things so
somebody I know it's basic that's why
it's like this is kind of a boring quite
I suspected that your answer would be
something like that but I think a lot of
people would be surprised they're like
well how is that that doesn't seem like
very much like how is that powering this
person through a hundred and twenty
miles of running every week it does if
you're eating well I mean you know
there's stuff like when I'm really
hungry you know add more almond butter
into like a smoothie and just more
calories but I'm getting clearly enough
because I'm not you know if I start
feeling like I'm losing weight then I
start adding more calories but I'm just
not a huge like eating tons of food all
the time and from what about writing I
always bring stuff so what you bring
when you're with almond butter packets
like packets of almond butter and this
one company I just found makes like a
bigger one so it's like five servings so
I can use that what company is that it's
a trail butter and they only have one
vegan formula so I'm gonna try to email
them and say can we make the coffee one
with vegan from the 200 so I used that
actually during the 200 mile race and it
was great cuz in between those eight
stations when I had like five hours ago
that yeah thing powered me and your
energy which is a great company they're
local here and they have like four to
five ingredients and so it's thicker
than a regular gel and it's almost like
a consistency of an almond butter and
they're like about 180 calories per
little packet of gel so I use that in
baby food packets and that's pretty much
what I eat and then even in these 200
mile races in between that's all I'm
eating but at the race aid stations I
sit down and they make that's one thing
unique about between a hundred and a 200
and 100 mile race I'm not eating emails
you have to sit down because you got to
go 20 miles again so they have a full
vegan gluten free selection there for
you yeah they have the big little free
vegan bin and there's a lot of people
there so including free vegans you fish
my one of my paces is not even a vegan
but he's trying to eat more vegan when
he was out there with us and he was
eating the gluten-free and goes this
stuff is good so they whip up you a
patty right there you have to wait for
you you know cuz they're making it to
order because you know not coming in
like in a hundred mile race a bunch of
meat but you gotta leave food out so
they cook it up you sit there a name
had gluten-free vegan bread I was like
so I would sit down and eat tons and
people are like wow how can you eat that
much so I'd have lentil soup then I
wanted the Pattie then I would have the
bread and then I would have hashbrowns
and then I would go again right so that
was a lot of fuel and then in between I
would do the almond butter and then your
energy and the baby foods do you do real
foods too like dates and yeah if they
have sweet potatoes out there but in
dates I carry those all the time they're
like dates are like one of my favorite
things for training because bars you
know it's like they have so many
different things I mean they even have
raw foods bars but I'd rather just have
dates for the sweetness and the
carbohydrate like the partner nature's
gel they are when I did the marathon to
sob in Morocco many years ago the stage
race mm-hmm I noticed like the guys that
were winning these races I'm like how do
they the packs look so small it's
because they look at your calorie
content you have to have a certain
amount of day they just had bags of
dates and that was the amount of
calories you know for the entire race
because it's three dates is like 120
calories so I'm like [ __ ] that's how
they got away from it I'm like taking
wrappers off my bars to make it lighter
in the bag and you know whatever else
have you just did that race once yeah
I'd like to do it again but it's just so
crazy now that's a crazy race but I know
thousand people yeah yeah exploded I
just had Fiona Oakes on yes documentary
about she's amazing she's doing funny I
know she's very funny
I'm like she's like really serious but
like really funny and a self-deprecating
right you're like you're amazing but
she's like ah no I don't like very good
I'm a [ __ ] runner oh how could you yeah
she's I want to see her documentary yeah
you should watch it it's good she's
really she's a cool lady I think it's
worth noting also like just on the
calorie thing and like how you eat every
day that you've been doing this so long
when when you go out on your daily 20
mile run or whatever it is that you're
doing that's not that it's it can't be
that taxing like people think oh my god
20 miles like I'd be in bed for a week
after that
yeah it's like taking pictures and
selfies and making videos do you do
who's taking all those pictures me so
how are you doing that when you're like
facing are you doing okay
are you do button so I set it up and got
to do the dance video dress of the Train
yeah yeah yeah good I know people are
like who follows you Truman can't be I
know because I was like somebody's
taking photos their photos really great
you write about yourself and like of
course I do it's just my phone or like
cell phone iPhone all right there no
excuses and that makes people smile too
because there's like oh we look forward
to seeing these funny videos that you do
don't do music videos and it just gets
people out the door because they're like
I don't [ __ ] like she's having fun okay
we're gonna go rent today right it makes
it less intimidating yeah you know
you're like I'm going to run this and
it's super scary with Truman and he's
wearing a ski ski goggles what is
happening here it looks like I mean
sometimes it looks like there's no it
looks like like you're you're like are
you on the set of Mad Max like it's
there something post-apocalypse so what
are you now you've done these two these
three to hundreds like what's next you
just go right into the next racer yeah I
had in between eleven daybreak for my
next hundred nine thousand days and I
yeah I'm like how luxurious do you Anna
you know but I'm going for my tent that
javelina 100 and last year I had did
Moab 240 because I was the first year
they had it and eleven days later did
the 100 by overnight never again never
again and then I'm like oh crap I have
to cuz I'm going for number 10 now so
yeah yeah so that's coming up when it's
next Friday I don't know uh-huh
but I love that race because you I wear
costume every year it's always right
before hell yeah it's like a big party
if I was ever to suggest somebody to do
their first hundred that wanted to be
kind of low-key about it it's loop it's
20-mile loops
do you have Elena it's like a party yeah
it's in the Arizona desert uh-huh it's
hot it's gonna be warm probably but I've
been looking at the temperature doesn't
look much over 80 so keeping my fingers
what's the costume you're gonna wear I'm
gonna be what does what does the name oh
my god they from Alice in Wonderland the
rabbit what is his name I'm blanking
right now no me too and I'm not good at
home well I was gonna be her and then it
was like no I got to be the the white
rat man whatever yes of course
my daughter was just the Mad Hatter in
play I can't I have had so many costumes
every year I'm something so yeah I got
this like styled in costume I broke you
know freakiness it's like it's okay we
can have a brand I know we can have I
ran 241 on my brain soon so yeah and I
just have to finish making my little hat
and I'm all set
uh-huh he's ready to like the full black
top hat with the plane so I'm gonna do
that I have to make like a little watch
on there and I have the little rabbit
ears on there and I'm curing a little
rabbit I was carry like a prop so I'll
pin it to the back of my pack a white
rabbit it's just getting more surreal
yeah you'll see the costume I love it
all right we got to wind this down but I
want to end this with some some
inspiration for people that that are
feeling stuck in their life or feeling
like maybe that ship has sailed
you know I think it's so inspiring what
you do and and the way that you do it it
just makes like I said it makes people
feel comfortable taking a leap of faith
or getting outside their comfort zone
because you make it fun and you make it
accessible so if somebody's sitting on
the couch or they're rubber-banding in
and out of whatever lifestyle habit
they're trying to adopt like how can how
can we get people to understand that the
things that you do are not necessarily
unique to you but available to everybody
they gotta get out and just find their
passion and just have fun don't don't go
into trying to be so serious maybe if
you want to start running or you want to
get outdoors to make yourself feel
better to start by hiking just get out
and breathe the air go out for a walk
and look at the flowers look at the
plants look at the trees I mean that to
me
just getting out is the first step you
have to become a run
do 100 miles or do whatever but get out
and then see what the world has to offer
and change of course change the way you
eat eating healthy definitely will help
your mindset - and I think that's a big
part of when I got into recovery that it
did help me was eating healthy you know
not eating the junk in the toxic
staffing just getting rid of toxicity in
my life so just get out and enjoy it and
just find your passion these things are
cumulative you know they're not they're
not unrelated to each other you start
taking care of yourself in one way and
then you're more more encouraged to take
care of yourself
in other ways and when I look at your
story and your life and your trajectory
I mean it's so dramatic and crazy that
you went from this place of where you
were to what you're doing now and you're
just continuing to crush it
you know it's just it's so awesome I was
meant to be on this planet for a reason
to inspire other there's always say you
know it's like I you know tried to
commit suicide and it's like it didn't
happen because I'm supposed to be here
so mm-hmm
well I'm glad you alright thank you cool
so the book is called reborn on the run
are you out like doing talk so like is
there a way for people that if they want
to come in yes you can actually if they
want to even get a copy they can get it
on Amazon or they can actually email me
my websites almost finished but they can
email me at diva 333 at gmail.com if
they want an autographed copy and I can
send that out to them and they can get
it through that way but my website will
be up and they'll be able to order it
sure you get your website done when your
book comes out it's you're too busy
running to find somebody to do it I mean
he came up with this great way he had to
base jump off of rock yeah exactly so we
just did it while I was out running the
240 he's like finally had time to sit
down because he's working two jobs and
he's a busybody and running and so but
yeah so it's fine that getting dim but
I'll be my next book signing is in
December first at running skirts in San
Diego and I'll be out of javelina doing
a book signing they'll be selling my
book there at the hundred mile or next
week so awesome and if people want to
connect with you online
at dirt diva three three three three how
many threes three three three what's the
deal with the head I am just obsessed
with the number three and three threes
is like way more luckier like it's a
better number and it's like a positive
number if you look up three three three
it's a very like the angels and positive
things are always around you when you
have that number and I see that when I
look at my watch or my phone a few times
a week I see three three three or I'll
see a car go by or I'll see those
numbers right now oh my god you know
what it's like five of three right now
if it was 333 right now I would do you
know but yeah I'm just obsessed with
that number there huh and then Instagram
Oh Instagram is dirty of a 333 and
Twitter is dirt diva 33 I think that for
some reason couldn't earn a degree and
then Facebook I have an athlete's page
because my regular page is full which is
like whatever mhm so I have an athlete's
page and Truman has a page too Truman
Duchess Truman have his own Instagram he
doesn't cuz like just keep us together
it's too complicated where's little paws
can't really use the phone that well yes
we just let him have a Facebook here's a
facebook athlete's room it has a lot of
personality I'm telling you if you've
never gotten a dose of Truman you're in
for a treat most everybody has seen him
around and they like their selfies like
my poor crew guy he was like out one of
the aid station and all you see is these
pictures of an his arm and Truman like
everybody's taking pictures of Truman
you as my army got really popular my oh
my god
awesome well you're super inspiring I
just want to recognize you for all the
amazing work that you're doing
it's really cool to follow your your
path and all your racing and all the fun
stuff that you do and the spirit in
which you do it and I just want you to
keep doing it thank you I will okay
you're coming by and talking appreciate
us here thank you for a so come back
anytime I'm hoping or running yes
human can do an interview everyone would
be great especially on the video yeah
all right gotcha thank you so much thank
you all right peace awesome flats
[Music]